[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
long ago humans and pokemon had not yet
learned to coexist
[Music]
this land
is the jesuit region
it will come to be known as the sinnoh
region
and at this time the ecology of its wild
pokemon remains unknown
therefore
many people still fear pokemon
and such people live together in
jubalife village
where this story begins
[Music]
your goal is to research the pokemon of
this region
[Music]
as a member of the galaxy expedition
team
an organization dedicated to studying
this land
you will strive to complete the first
pokedex in the region
research begins at a base camp from
which you'll embark on excursions
you can catch wild pokemon with
pokeballs
[Music]
be warned
not every pokemon is so easy to catch
in such an event
one option is to challenge them to a
battle
command your pokemon to weaken the
opponent and it should be easier to
catch
pokemon behaviors vary in the isui
region
they may live in groups
or they may flee upon sensing your
presence
the aggressive sort will attack without
hesitation
[Music]
some are much more powerful than you if
danger comes your way
run
it's quite the important research tip
back at your base camp you can let your
team of pokemon recover their health
professor lavinton a researcher on the
galaxy expedition team will provide
research support
report back to the professor with any
and all research and the information
will be entered into the pokedex
there are various research tasks of note
including number caught and times you've
seen it use moves
as you fulfill these tasks such entries
will populate
[Music]
the central hub for your research is
jubilife village
it's a great place to prepare for
excursions
visit the general store where you can
purchase items with in-game currency
or head to the craftworks to craft using
the materials you've gathered
[Music]
the pokemon you've caught can be left at
pastures
[Applause]
the clothier and hairdresser let you
customize your clothing and your
hairstyle as well
when you feel like it head to the
photography studio to take pictures with
your pokemon
juba life village is also home to the
headquarters of the galaxy expedition
team
[Music]
alongside commander comodo
and captain cylene
you will carry out pokemon research and
survey missions
in doing so
you will grow as a team member and
eventually explore new areas of the
region
certain pokemon with special powers will
allow you to ride them
[Music]
with the aid of your pokemon
your research will take you to greater
areas of the region
eventually
you will come to learn about noble
pokemon respected by the people of jesui
frenzied by a mysterious power
these pokemon will stand up against you
for just such an occasion special foams
have been created to calm them
[Music]
dodge powerful attacks and create
opportunities to challenge it to pokemon
battles
quell the noble pokemon through various
methods
vast lands
[Music]
and wild threats await you
[Music]
and what is the mythical pokemon arceus
[Music]
the story of humans and pokemon begins
right here in the jesui region
pokemon legends arceus
available january 28th on the nintendo
switch system digital pre-orders are
available now on nintendo eshop